think we speak about needs to be within
context okay so when you spoke you said
compare to my peers right yeah so age of
me so so maybe compared to your peers
you may not be average that's why that
was my evidence however however if we go
to another context right and then we
compare you to people like
Rihanna Beyonce who are one millionaires
hang on right
yeah one second you can because I'll
tell you why let me explain why right
when you meet a guy right you can be
very pretty you could be very attractive
you could be like all of these things
right but um he'll still look at you as
average because oh if if he if look
there's always it depends what you
compare the average with okay so like
you said with your peers you can apply
that to that but if you apply average on
a larger scale okay where people are
millionaires people are mad famous
millions of followers they all look at
you as average compared to that person
no but we have to look overall because
you've got to remember people are being
brainwashed out here they're looking at
Rihanna they're looking at Beyonce
they're looking at all the problems all
of these people yes the whole thing if
you don't mind can I just finish what I
was saying so that's the first thing I
was going to say is in context right who
you're comparing yourself to because
nowadays is guys are looking for girls
of the majority of guy because look I'm
I'm a woman right but all my life I've
I'm Road I'm Hood all my friends are
savages they're all Road man I don't I
don't chill with girls I've got one
female that's my friend all my friends
are males so I hear them when they speak
this younger generation a lot of them
are actually looking for girls with
money that's what they want girls with
money girls with cars girls with like
that's that's how they're they're
thinking now their thinking is
completely different so a normal basic
nine to five working person or or or
working class or whatever is average to
them it's average because they're seeing
these things every day so that's the
first point I wanted to make right the
second point I wanted to make is people
are like oh you know the man should be
in control the man's um uh you have to
listen to the man and the man's got the
power but really and truly right if
you're married right or you're in a
serious relationship with a man you're
the one that's in control you're the one
that's in power and I'll tell you why
because when your husband respects you
right he'll do anything for you you ring
him and say to him look I need milk he's
dropping everything and he's coming he's
bringing milk if you even if I say to
him I need this or something's happened
or he's coming he's coming running
straight for you so really you're
actually in control as long as there's
respect there right and there's the love
there and you're playing your role when
he's playing his his role they say that
a woman is the neck to a man's head so
you can turn his head whichever way you
want to turn his head you just gotta
know how to
what were you gonna say something I
really hate how being a single mother
diminishes your value as a human being
how how you can go from a tense and the
average like oh now you're a five
because you're singing but that says
nothing about who you are as a person
this is nothing about your Mastery about
your talent about the discipline that
takes together
bro
listen at the end of the day at the end
of the day yeah you have to just respect
what the market wants what at the end of
the day you know how much money let me
just finish my because I'll let you not
talk do your thing I will do my thing
yeah at the end of the day if you don't
care what the market wants and you
talking you tell yourself oh I'm not
average I'm not average bro like you're
just gonna continue losing bruv you
should maybe understand the market guess
what Coca-Cola understands its Market
that's why Coca-Cola is successful bro
so you can be deluded and think armor 10
and this because I'm I'm got money and I
went to this school and blah blah blah
like I bro I do these podcasts the same
thing and these women come and say the
same thing because I went to this school
and I've got money but the market does
not care about that yeah and I'm sorry
and I'm sorry to say it I'm sorry to say
like you're saying Oh but you know uh
single mother diminishing who you are as
a person no you could be a great person
and be a single mom you can be an
excellent person but at the end of the
day the market for the most part is not
going to want to come up here
what's going on
come on the man I said man
conversation thank you it says something
about your decision making if you become
a single mother
oh it's something about your decision
making maybe you don't pick the right
guy so abusive women that choose lovely
amazing men that just decide to be
physically abusive because I chose that
yeah is that what you're saying so I
chose to be a single divorcee because of
a individual's choice to be violent is
that what you're saying your choice to
get in a relationship with him oh
because it's like it's a man it says
life life turns out better if you take
accountability for your choices
sometimes okay I disagree
an abusive man he's wrong I agree with
you
where do we take accountability
so maybe maybe sorry Paul can I just I
have to say I disagree with you there
I'm definitely disagree with you then
I'll tell you why look I'm 38 I'm not a
young girl I've been married and I've
been divorced I've got experience I've
had a kid you know I've been there I've
done that so if somebody gets married at
a young age right they're young
right so they're not that clued right
look let me start from the look we
always talk about a problem but we never
ever get to the court of why that
problem occurs but everybody's here so
everyone's doing away as a young girl
I'm sure you'll all agree with me okay
as a young girl we are brainwashed we
are sold a fairy tale right we are all
thinking oh we're gonna wear this white
dress and we're gonna get married we're
going to be in love and no we shouldn't
have been taught that we should have
been taught the realness marriage is
very hard it's a struggle you've got to
make sure you know who your married look
and also people change over time
somebody who can marry them and when you
married him they were okay and over time
gradually they got mental breakdown they
they became a psychopath they became uh
anti-social but again we all grew up in
the same society and people of different
outcomes based on their choices so if
you make a choice can I finish what I'm
saying I think I think what you're
saying everything that we say has to be
within context you know some people
might get married and the husband dies
and it becomes single mother you know
we're not talking about exceptions we're
talking about the rule or the majority
of single mothers widows no but does it
go the other way do does Men's value
diminish when they become no it doesn't
no because they can just get up and they
can go and run away personally for me
personally I don't I'm not into the guys
with kids that's not my thing but in
general no I mean most guys I know that
have kids say it helps them in dating
girls like it
yeah no if I can just get up and start
all over again he can listen
when it comes to men but as soon as it's
not about accountability it's about
outcomes like what outcomes do you get
and and the outcomes that single mothers
have a harder time in dating a single
woman
and the outcome for men is often times
when men not always but oftentimes when
men have kids their outcomes are better
they get more girls because women like
to see women like to see a guy that can
take care of a kid it signals to us that
like you know again it's not my thing
personally can I add on to that because
I I am well I'm not I'm single mom I'm
engaged I'm getting married however
before I got engaged and I was it was me
and my child
um it is so so the the guy he can just
literally leave and go and start a whole
new life we remarry have a kid you
however he's not going to take that kid
with him he that woman doesn't have to
ask for worry about that child you're
the one who's going to keep that child
with you 24 7. so if you try to decide
to date right it's not as simple you
can't just go out and date you've got to
think about your child especially if
it's a little girl or a boy you've got
to know who you're bringing to your
house you've got to know who you're
bringing around your child and then
let's say for example like even when
you're married it's the child's own
father he starts to get jealous of that
child he'll start telling you oh I'm not
getting any time anymore so how do you
think a guy who's not even the father of
that child is going to fill would you
want would you want your brother to date
a single mother over a single woman
okay hold on all else equal everybody
wants a person without a child versus a
person with a child that's going to be
true all else equal the reason why men
tend to get away with it more than women
because women are often the ones taking
care of the kid now you might think in
your mind well I know some single dads
are really successful but single dads
that fight for custody is already a
minority of a minority so you're already
probably selecting for pretty successful
guys so I think three single dads that
would say that again single dads that
are fighting for custody of kids who can
take care of their kids you're already
selecting for a pretty rare guy yeah
right because they can't they don't
typically win no because they don't
typically fight for it they usually just
cut it around but the reason is like
I've talked to different attorneys about
this and the reason most attorneys will
tell guys not to fight for custody
because it's because it's so expensive
attorney too no no they tell them not to
fight because oftentimes they won't win
because when when a court is trying to
figure out who's going to get custody of
the kids it's very it's very expensive
it's like do you want to waste your life
savings when you're most likely or not
going to win no no no none of this is
true you can go you can go you can look
up all the numbers and all the sets if
we want the reason why men typically
don't fight is because one they don't
because if they fight and they're in a
bad place to win because they haven't
been taking care of the kid they're not
going to have a good account from the
church when the judge is looking when
the judge let me finish let me finish
the point when the judge is looking at
who gets custody it's not about who puts
up the better defense in court who's got
the more expensive lawyer it's who spent
most time with the child so if the mom
has spent 95 of the time with the kid
doesn't matter how much you pay to a law
you're not going to win she's a
housewife when men do fight for custody
they win 60 of the time but but the
problem the problem is like women can
make it so the dad doesn't even see the
kid and then go to court and then say
whose fault is that wait hold on wait
wait no no no wait wait stop stop stop
stop stop hold on you just went on a
whole spiel about take accountability
for your decisions blah blah and now
you're saying what is the mom playing
hide and go seeking what exactly what do
you take accountability what do you mean
when you say the wife has made it so the
husband can't take care of the kids well
they're they're you've never heard of
cases where women don't let the dads see
the kid hold on hold on you wait wait
earlier you said we were going to talk
about exceptions you want to talk about
the rules so don't give me the Hide and
Go
[Music]
what percentage um that's a good
question
um
I don't know because in the UK if that
be the case and I work in the industry
it's 275 to get a c101 application to go
to the court for contact for your child
it isn't what it is in America it's very
easy I can go out and do a bottle for
275. so I don't want to hear that excuse
because I can go to court and police can
turn up at my door if I go against that
order that's what I'm trying to say it's
always expensive what is the what is the
most expensive bad it's child custody
the most expensive thing is the most
expensive
so go ahead
right and I just want to say
a few things
I was picked
I was in a relationship it was abusive
and nobody can't tell me that with
hindsight you can't see that there's
loads of red flags
so when he asked me to marry him and I
said no if he was a lost man enough I
wouldn't marry you
I saved myself from getting married and
getting stuck in a relationship so yes I
was a single parent whose dad the
child's dad asked me to marry him and I
thought about it and I thought not on
your life and actually said if you were
the last man in earth I would marry you
that's the last thing I remembered I was
that cold on the floor
you know why because I couldn't imagine
myself my mom and dad were married and I
thought to myself this guy I got into it
this guy picked me I never picked him
this guy picked me I fell in love got
into a relationship it was abusive and
I thought to myself the last thing I
need is to get married and tied to this
man forever so if I knew that there were
red flags before when he I could have
turned around and said oh yeah I must
say you know I mean I want to get
married he I proposed to me had the ring
one knee everything I could have said
yeah
then I would have been stuck in an
abusive relationship as a married woman
and then I would have got divorced and
still be a single woman
who'd been married before and an abusive
relationship but I decided no so too
many women out there they think you know
what that will go by they see a red flag
oh that's nothing they see this that was
nothing and then they go along with that
oh yeah let's get married now I could
have gone along with it everybody was
like yeah on the outside you threw
together it's working he drops you
shopping he picks you up he takes you
here we takes you there
but I knew in my heart that he was
abusive nobody couldn't see it and I
decided that rather than get caught up
in the great big wedding scene knock it
on its head so when women are talking
about they're not average as a single
parent I had to be different I had to
stop going out there and thinking to
yourself you know what I need a man I
didn't need a man I know I needed to do
I made the choice I needed to look after
my child I needed to make sure I didn't
have any more children I needed to make
sure that I become a positive role model
for him and make sure that he had male
mentors out there so much so that
eventually when I got back to the first
man that I was in love with by the time
we got back together again he was a
single parent
he was willing to take me as a single
parent
and
I took him as a single parent so as far
as I'm concerned don't go out if you're
a single parent look for other single
parents
if you can't find no one that you trust
that you could hang over to
single parents unite single men who are
parents go have a single women who are
parents because the women who are out
there now nobody wants to be average
everybody wants to be above average but
you know what I'm average this is who I
am I've met somebody average we got on
great and it works I don't want to find
some of a fancy car when I met him he
never wasn't even driving eventually got
a fancy car and I got it to drive he
gave it to me but you don't hang your
hat too high women out there and the
average makeup don't make you more than
average intelligence don't make you more
than average education don't make you
more than average the clothes that you
wear that make you more than average the
podcast you go on to do not make you
more than average it makes you popular
Outdoors out talking let me finish let
me finish let me experience on it
I can't expand if I don't finish talking
again because I'm in English I'm
Caribbean I'm not African so shut up and
let me finish when I finish talking I've
been sitting here
okay they will be on here talking
speak for yourself say that you
are the best foreign
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible